Okay, I want to answer this question. So he said he's truthfully anxious about getting both sites ranked. Okay. So, and then he asked, should he just follow you know our training, or should he infuse backlink so here's what I'm going to.
And by the way, backlinking is is the juice that you add on the, and the end of it it's the steroids.
I think I called it digital steroids, or maybe I call it something else I, I called it something I had a live that I did when I was in Africa and I'll try to link that up.
But first of all, how long does it take. That is, it's really impossible to say, okay, I've had sites where I've been like yeah this looks like low hanging fruit, it's not going to be super difficult.
And I'm going to do all this different stuff just like I did with this other city, and I'm going to rank in three months, and guess what I ranked in three months in the city that looked more competitive, and then this new one.
I did the exact same thing and it took me six months so there's really no way for you to know what I would plan on Edward is if you did the due diligence correctly if you follow the training and you made sure that the, you know, the people that
are in the maps were not the same people in the organic, and you made sure there was they didn't have a ton of backlinks they'd have super, you know crazy content, and they didn't have super age domains all these different things right you checked all those boxes.
I would always plan on and I would tell my business owner or maybe you don't want to tell your business owner but you just want to plan, I would, I always plan on about six months okay six to nine months and I know in my head, my goal is to get it between
four and six, but I always plan on six to nine months because then I don't let anybody down then I can budget my, you know, how much profit I'm making versus my ads, all these different things I always in my mind, from when I get a deal to when it's ranked
six to nine months. That's why I do a six month contract. Okay.
So, that's what I would plan on. Now, if you're in like a very obscure niche with no competition, or you're in a really small town, or you're in, you just did good due diligence, it could happen sooner, it definitely could I've had sites.
I had one site ranked in less than 90 days, and I didn't do any backlinks I didn't do anything special in fact we didn't really do a lot. Okay.
We didn't do a lot but it ranked quickly so I wouldn't worry too much about that what I would do is I would manage expectations that's what you need to focus on.
You can control what you can control but you can't control how fast it ranks, you can control that you're doing activities every day that are going to make your website rank, based on data that we've used that's worked for us that we train you on.
You can you can control how much content you put every day. How many pages you put every day how many new photos, how if you add a backlink, all these different things you can control those.
You can control how you manage the business owners expectations, but at the end of the day, Edward, you cannot control how fast Google ranks you.